I've had we've had pretty good guests on
the show mm-hmm
we've had some rockers we've had some
UFC fighters we've had you know actors
and whatnot a lot of comedians and this
next gentleman I used to go I don't know
why he doesn't invite me anymore to his
show but um but not like he used to
invite me all the time to the show and
I'm like oh cool I get to do craig
ferguson's again right we never did this
talk she by the way by the way never was
invited I stopped doing the radio show
in May of last year so that's why you
haven't been asked on it I quit last May
did you really quit this why I told you
I was gonna oh that's what you did say
that so that's why I haven't been get
any calls right because I also have not
been invited on my own and the reason
I'm reading this cold coffee thing is
I'm thinking do I dare drink this I feel
I have to have something because I feel
I might have a bacterial waterborne
bacterial disease because it's gonna
tell people how did you tell people yeah
okay just he lives on a compound and
then you go in well I live I live in a
compound you guys know about very
wealthy compound I was coming at my comp
it's actually it's I'm so wealthy it's
two blocks from me I'm caught at my
compound I noticed one of my many garden
fentons was blocked up now you know me
you know me you love fountain Bobby you
know what I'm like I learned a bloke's
fight and I go crazy I'm like what's the
point
yeah so I go to the phone and there's a
little tube but it's a it's a lady hold
it's a you know holding a water carrier
yeah it's usually a little boy peeing no
no no my bad it's a it's a lady in a
toga pouring a jug of water into another
jug of war right so I noticed that the
little stream is not working I go ah so
I go the front works in the back and I
see the little hose is disconnected
so I go to connect the hose and it still
doesn't work so I think I must be
blocked so then I go and
put it to my mouth and I blow to see if
there are leaves or stuff wrong it would
you would do right and then I think this
is insane
there could be bacteria in this war and
now that's what I was thinking that's
I'm gonna get sued bacteria that lives
in aquariums or swampy little areas but
it can be pathogenic if it goes inside
like the human body and I got it
remember was a dream my breasts I might
do that bring your eyes in your breasts
now or another day okay there are
antibiotics too but this is my problem
antibiotics are becoming less effective
all right because if you you your body
gets immune to it well no just the
bacteria is the visible Craig I know you
get them I want you to finish your
thought all right but I want to say this
to you right now yeah um my nickname on
the show is the slop King which means
it's the opposite of being woke I don't
know anything right so that is why you
know you might think to yourself this
guy's dumb I'm really glad you
interrupted me for that why I'm saying
by Metiria is becoming resistant to
antibiotics because bacteria evolves
very quickly and the big drum big drug
companies are no longer Putin R&D money
and antibiotics do you know that do you
know how I know yeah because antibiotics
cure you but yeah they don't want to
cure you they want you to be chronically
manageable they don't want to take the
disease away they want to give you a
drug for the rest of your life that's
why Big Pharma always block certain like
breakthroughs in medicine but I never
make it to the United States because why
would they give you something that they
cannot supply or sell medicines for
anymore I ran into a guy at oaks by your
house it's a little play
Kampai Kampai
and there was a white dude there
hippyish kind of guy you know the long
hair and he was telling me about how
they found a cure for cancer through
like some delete like some sort of plant
it was it my broader question to you is
is that do you think that they have like
cures from diseases that are in the
marketplace that they're just hiding
from the public for sure do you think so
even Cuba has better control of their of
lung cancer than they do in the United
States you go to Cuba to get treated for
lung cancer yeah that's insane to me
where do you go with for the border
thing you know that thing that we go
like - Craig I uh listen you can't say
that one is our word that is not URI
okay if you were woke you would know
that it's a good show to make you feel
better some girl wrote in and said that
she got Pseudomonas from her contact
lenses and nearly lost her vision when
you go blind
[Music]